i think some people turn off the
humanity when they go to work
um you know they they they may be you
know
loving parents and loving friends and
loving you know
uh children to their own parents and yet
for some reason
there's a switch that they think that
that's irresponsible to do at work now
i'm not talking about necessarily
wearing your heart on your sleeve every
day there is something called emotional
professionalism you know if you're
having a bad day you can say listen i'm
a little off my game today but you can't
sit in the meeting with your arms folded
and be grumpy and give one-word answers
that's that's emotionally unprofessional
you know you can have hard feelings but
you can't go around screaming and
yelling at people you know you can have
um so i think there's a there's
emotional professionalism but i think
for some reason especially as people
make their way up the ranks um
they think that expressing any kind of
emotion is a sign of weakness um even
that word vulnerability we talk you know
it's such a common word now being talked
about in in the business world that you
have to be vulnerable to this day it
makes some people feel very
uncomfortable i don't want to be
vulnerable
well all vulnerability means
is saying things like i don't know
or i need help or i'm overwhelmed or can
you you know can you help me do this
because i don't know how to do this or
i've been promoted to a position where
maybe i need more training
and the reason we're afraid of saying
that is for fear that it makes us look
weak which will then damage our careers
the reality is the total opposite by
saying i don't know means someone can
help us but instead we choose to lie
hide and fake very often which
eventually gets revealed enough stress
piled on on that lying hiding and faking
collapses either professionally or
personally we either we either feel the
stress or or the projects that we're
working on start to go haywire and very
often when we get to those points
everybody knows anyway um and uh the
amazing thing that i've learned is when
you say
can somebody help me
we're surrounded by people who would
love to help us they just didn't think
we needed it because we acted as if we
didn't so i think a large part of it is
is quite frankly fear fear that if i
express these things that'll that people
will think i'm not qualified for my job
um uh where the the uh the the opposite
is true and remember when you are in a
position of leadership you don't
actually have to be better
at doing the job that the people you
lead you have to be responsible for
taking care of them to make sure they're
good at their job but for some reason we
think that
i have to be better than you at your own
job because i'm the leader completely
false i just have to make sure that
you're equipped you have the tools the
training and the psychological safety to
come to be the best you can be even if
it's better than me